let's talk about evolution 3.5 billion
years ago stuff happened mal evolved
mostly by drawing on walls chiseling
rocks into shapes in hits in each other
finally though man's true purpose is
going to be achieved because driveclub
and PlayStation 4 are set to rewrite the
rules of the rating genre and it starts
with a masterpiece of evolution the game
app that's right you will give you the
power to purchase and play games on your
own terms with true freedom of choice
here's how the natural selector you like
to pick and choose what you want upgrade
an add-on as you play as an active
PlayStation Plus member you can enjoy
driveclub playstation plus edition which
comes with all game modes in a great
selection of cars tracks and locations
for free if you want to upgrade to get
everything with one single purchase you
can do that then you'll have access to
all the cars tracks and locations and
take all the points and trophies you've
earned for your club with you you're the
master of your own destiny as long as
your PlayStation Plus membership is
active you have the power but because
this is dr club there was another option
here's the gaming carnivore you know
what you want and want everything now
you can buy driveclub from your local
game store or buy the full digital game
online that's absolutely everything all
of the coolest cars tracks and locations
around the world
bleep package you can also get some cool
bonus content if you reserve driveclub
from your local game store all the
content in one place ensures your top of
the food chain either way building a
community is an intrinsic part of our
DNA now get your ps4 join a club recruit
your friends and enjoy the evolution of
rating with the game you want when you
want it that's revolution in a hairpin
drive club drive together win together
Spencer